battlefield 2042 gameplay has been
revealed the director's cut trailer for
death stranding is dropping on september
8th a brand new fortnight event is on
the way and ghost to sushima has added
one of the most adorable and greatest
updates of all time i'm persia happy
friday and welcome to your gamespot news
update
ea has revealed a new gameplay trailer
for battlefield 2042's specialist system
which is based on battlefield's four
classes assault support engineer and
recon
each specialist has one unique specialty
and trait but the rest of the loadout
can be customized there are 10
specialists at launch with more of them
to be revealed soon battlefield 2042
developer dice has shed some light on
one of the notable changes it's making
to a particular part of the multiplayer
game due to feedback from the alpha it
was announced on twitter that operator
falk's s21 sierra pistol had significant
enough issues to lead to an overall
imbalance to gameplay the pistol is
capable of reviving players at range but
that proved to be too overpowering as a
result dice is changing the pistol so it
will only be capable of healing at a
range but not reviving battlefield 2042
launches in october but there is a beta
that's supposed to be dropping sometime
in september so it might not be long at
all before you can go hands-on with the
multiplayer
the death strandings director's cut
trailer which was edited by kojima
himself is set to be released on
september 8th at 12 a.m pacific 3 a.m
eastern through the official kojima
productions youtube channel kojima who
said he poured his soul into the trailer
asked people to please watch it with a
sound environment if possible the
release of the new death stranding
trailer comes one day before sony's next
big showcase on september 9th where more
information about the latest ps5 games
is expected to be announced
the death stranding director's cut
features a ton of new content and
enhanced gameplay features this includes
more weapons equipment vehicles modes
and missions along with additional areas
to explore expanded storylines and ui
enhancements a trailer released during
gamescom showed off a number of these
new features the director's cut is
launching on september 24th for the
playstation 5.
fortnite season 7 is coming to a close
very soon but operation sky fire is
looking to put a bow on what has been a
mini player's favorite season of
fortnite chapter 2. the alien invasion
season played host to a busier than
usual content pipeline including the
cosmic summer event the ariana grande
rift tour and the return of the wild
weeks the next interactive finale event
for season seven is called operation sky
fire and it will take place just once on
sunday september 12th at 1pm pacific 4
pm eastern players can jump into the
event playlist in a lobby with up to 15
friends to experience it all together
though it's unclear if that means each
player shares the experience only with
those in their menu lobby or if they
will see strangers in the same space as
we did during the rift tour there will
also be no replays for this event unlike
some others such as the zero point
finale which remained a playlist for
several weeks into season 6. epic also
wants players to finish everything that
they can before operation skyfire
suggesting that whatever happens during
the event is going to have some serious
implications for season 8.
from its scenic landscapes to its sharp
action ghosts of tsushima has a lot of
strong selling points one of the best
and most distinctive features though is
the game's collection of adorable foxes
these wild canines lead players to inari
shrines and definitely deserve a pat on
the head afterwards for their hard work
a new update for gosu tsushima and its
iki island expansion has added an amount
of charm to the foxes in the game that
is sure to melt your heart as spotted by
twitter's most important account can you
pet the dog foxes will now happily tap
their feet on the ground in anticipation
of a belly rub
there are of course other animals that
you can pet on iki island but nothing
beats the enthusiasm of a little fox
doing a little tap dance so cute for
more on the ghost of tsushima expansion
and the director's cut enhancements make
sure you head on over to gamespot.com to
check out our review
if you ask me every single game should
add dogs that you can pet it just makes
everything better is there a video game
dog that you love that you can't pet let
me know in the comments below and of
course thank you so much for watching
i'll catch you on your next gamespot
news update
[Music]
you